brought to you by the witcher 3 wild
hunt available now hey I want to talk to
you all about civilization beyond earth
that can commit October of last year
Chris waters you had an interesting
phone call and the last week yeah it
wasn't developers are one of the co-lead
designers Dave McDonough about the new
expansion for it right so it's called
the rising tide and it's basically like
what if you could just call in as water
is that that's the pitch no that's like
the real lame cool-guy way to say it all
right i just gave to you but no it's
yeah so you can build us one of the big
things is being able to build
settlements on the water as freely as
you can on land and so that just you
know you can imagine with water and
civilization traditionally just being a
barrier to exploration yeah or something
to sort of control vaguely with military
might and be it's sort of a passage or
transit lanes now having it as territory
you can exert some control over you have
some bigger investment in there's a lot
of like potentially game-changing yesica
that fundamentally changes the attack
patterns or like in terms of like what
what taking over like specific areas
because it used to be like like where
you built in relation to like where you
could build next or where you could
expand to was always defined by the
water and so can you like build the
bases right off the bat on the water can
you build like lots of how much detail
if they got into a bed like Heather's
the word yeah they're sort of keeping a
lot of it under wraps because it's
coming out in fall so they're gonna be
doing more sort of press rollouts and
stuff presumably as that comes along I
don't know if you can start with in with
a oceanic sieve I imagine I imagine you
can because they I mean they have to
make the water world map possible right
just the whole blue ocean but yeah you
can like you can have an empire that's
mainly aquatic you can you know it
really does sort of change where you're
going to be able to expand your
territory to I don't know if like you
know is it isn't it isn't a quad city
gonna grow to the point where like
because you can beat a civilization game
with just one city yeah with two cities
you know will it be able to be that rich
and grow that big and that raises like
being on water raises a lot of questions
and
terms of you know how do you restrict
passage how do you you know yeah you can
see resources and stuff so that's going
to be important but terrain on land has
all these military implications yes like
bempton passes and valleys and stuff
like that whereas water is pretty much
like it can you go is there any
underwater stuff in this at all is there
there's I mean you'll be able to see
like different layers of the sea like
deep-sea resources and shallow resources
but there's no other layer like sub
there's no submarine layers no XCOM Tara
from the deep yeah orbital layer
equivalent below the sea it's all just
sort of one surface layer so that's one
of the big things uh that's pretty
intriguing not rising tide then there
also overhauling the diplomacy system
okay entirely breather uh yeah they
they're sort of talking a big game about
it and then not saying what the details
are right of course but like there I
guess the thing is traits so when you
look at you know when you have a certain
civilization leader let's say the
historical saves they would be
militaristic or industrious or whatever
depending on their history and their
kind of persona these traits are aimed
to sort of do a similar thing but
they're also they can change you can
determine what your traits are so you
adopt them and player and other sibs
change their traits depending on the
course of the game cool so you're not
stuck in like one type of like class
almost for the enzyme yeah it's like
diplomacy it is like kind of static in a
lot of games to me it's like
everything's peaceful until some dudes
get cranky I'm the peaceful race so I'm
gonna do this or I'm the like this like
your you so set on your table before
you've even sat down on it yeah and so
the idea with traits is not only to sort
of make things a little more visible in
terms of what people's intentions are
but also too I guess add some more
complex layering in terms of what kind
of diplomatic things are available to do
with different partners yeah you know if
you have like traits maybe there's
something new you can do there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that they're adding
in that's not you not sort of the
marquee items you had new units you saw
the screenshots there's like a new biome
that's like the lava world cool
primordial earth but a couple new biomes
yeah yeah two new biomes I think for new
civilizations
factions whatever but the thing I think
it interests me is sort of thinking
about this you know at the expansion's
history with civilization like
civilization 5 came out right lots of
people love that game civil'zation five
gods and kings came out and added in
faiths and religions and spies and all
these systems that really change game
change in a significant way house if
I've played and so my question for the
rising tide is like you know the
reception for beyond Earth was kind of
lukewarm yeah in a lot of ways people
sort of felt I think with the monolithic
civ5 gods and Kings sort of being the
reigning civ champ for so long and then
there's so much excitement about that
like a new Alpha Centauri is coming out
like you're going out into the alien
realms you're gonna be able to like do
so much like menu sky's the limit right
yeah and you were saying we were kind of
talking about it earlier that they kind
of maybe were a bit too safe with us
yeah the kind of recognizing that they
and they own it like it that a GDC
post-mortem uh the to co-lead designers
are saying you know it one of the things
that they wish they had done more was go
further diverge further from
civilization cuz you know it's their
first time clearing a sip yes to young
developers like there are their mid-20s
I think they're not quite that y all
right but they're like our age okay are
like I don't know exactly they're not
sid meier levels of ID's but no they're
not sid meier you know they're not that
you know he still works there and he
consulted on the game but it was really
these two guys leading the charge and i
think they wanted that you know the
thing they kept talking about in these
preview events is like how do you remain
civet the reinvented for an alien planet
where anything is possible and future
technology where you could do anything
and turns out we learn about that turns
out waters on planets so yeah so they're
taking a shot at the water hopefully
this will be sort of their chance to be
a little more ambitious and a little
more bold or divergent and final
question is this a paid for expansion
pack oh yeah oh yeah it's gonna be like
30 bucks okay so okay 30 I between su
see what the reception is to that it'll
be year since it came out it's hopefully
one stinky about this fall so yeah we'll
see and that maybe they'll have some
some deals I don't know but game of the
year edition or whatnot yeah who knows
who knows awesome i'll keep your
years tunes to gamespot com for more on
civilizations beyond Earth rising tide
there I got it let us know in the
comments more than rising sun rising
tide it's [ __ ] the rising tide of
both money